Now and again, you might stumble across an
entry in the SCP Foundation Archive that is
far more than meets the eye.
As you are probably already aware, sometimes
the Foundation’s numerical SCP designations
can be referencing an entity, a creature,
an object, a location, or even a combination
of linked anomalies all sharing a version
of the same number.
Such is partly the case with SCP-4812.
In this instance, the designation number ‘4812’
doesn’t refer to one singular item or entity.
Instead, it is more of a collective designation,
an umbrella term for three distinct, separate,
but connected anomalies.
We’ve got a lot of ground to cover here,
so without further ado, let’s take a look
at SCP-4812, better known collectively as
‘Wrath’.
We’ll begin in a cavern deep beneath Alès,
in the south of France,
where we find the first of the entities to
share the designation SCP-4812.
This creature, large and without its own distinct
form, is referred to as SCP-4812-S. It possesses
a number of long appendages that protrude
from its amorphous body, each one covered
in a sticky, adhesive, a sort of glue-like
substance.
In addition, each appendage, as well as the
rest of SCP-4812-S’ body, is covered in
fine hair that is hydrophobic, meaning that
it does not absorb water, and in fact, actively
repels it.
These tendrils extend deep into the walls
of the cavern surrounding the creature.
SCP-4812-S also has an inherent, latent ability
to affect anyone that visually perceives it.
In other words, look upon this creature at
your own peril.
And we don’t mean that looking at it will
drive you mad.
The fact is that nobody has been able to look
directly at this creature without suffering
a horrific, grizzly death.
Upon taking even the quickest glimpse at SCP-4812-S,
the person observing will suffer the same
effect they would if their eyes, brain, and
entire nervous system had been dipped in caustic
acid.
Yes, this creature instantly melts down on
a molecular level anyone who is brave enough
or foolish enough to look directly at it.
That means a pain unlike any you could imagine,
bleeding through the skin and all orifices,
paralysis, asphyxiation, and then death, in
that order.
Humans cannot directly interact with the creature
unless it is submerged in total darkness,
where they cannot perceive it visually.
The anomalous hazard of this entity even extends
to photos or video recordings of SCP-4812-S.
However, the effect is not as immediate or
violent when someone just looks at an image
or video of it.
Still, you might want to check that your brain
isn’t melting after this video’s over
- just to be safe.
Beyond killing anyone that sees it, SCP-4812-S
does very little, staying quite still in its
cave behind the maximum security doors the
Foundation has put in place at the entrance.
So, that’s our first of the SCP-4812s.
Who’s next?
How about SCP-4812-E, an approximately fifteen-meter-tall
humanoid made of platinum?
This entity appears vaguely skeletal, with
traces of tungsten and other metal compounds
in its composition.
SCP-4812-E remains at a constant body temperature
of 0.0000000031 Kelvin or almost negative
460 degrees Fahrenheit.
However, this entity can also absorb the heat
around it without changing its own temperature,
reducing a cell at room temperature to absolute
zero in around sixteen seconds flat.
And it’s because of this that SCP-4812-E
is often surrounded by a layer of frozen air
and water.
Much like the other creature it shares a designation
with, close interactions with SCP-4812-E are
often deadly.
Stand too close, and the air around you would
drop in temperature rapidly, the water within
your body would freeze, and in seconds you
would die.
Even with the use of a specially insulated
suit, you would be lucky to gain a few short
moments of added protection.
The only thing that weakens SCP-4812-E’s
effect is to expose it to extreme heat, although
this does not stop the temperature absorption
entirely, just slows it.
But it’s through the constant application
of high temperatures that the Foundation has
been able to keep SCP-4812-E contained in
a thermally controlled vault kept intensely
hot at all times.
Finally, we have the last of the three, designated
as SCP-4812-K, and we recommend anyone with
a bug phobia to look away now.
This creature is an enormous winged insect,
almost like a cross between a stag beetle
and a scorpion in some of the physical traits
it shares with them.
While its size might be significantly bigger,
measuring 180 meters long, the insect possesses
two large pincers, four legs, four wings that
extend from its back, and a long, segmented
tail with a pointed barb at the tip.
Yes, this creepy-crawly would need a lot more
than just a can of Raid to get rid of it.
But perhaps most strangely of all is SCP-4812-K’s
face, not the typical insect eyes and mouth
you would expect, but the face of a human
male.
Much like its cavern dwelling counterpart,
SCP-4812-K tends to not do all that much when
left alone.
It can usually be found flying through the
upper stratosphere, only really moving when
it flaps its wings.
You might have a hard time trying to spot
it, though, as its body is coated in reflective
chitin.
In other words, the bug’s exoskeleton refracts
light away from it and makes it almost invisible.
While the SCP Foundation has made attempts
to secure and contain this gigantic flying
insect after they learned of its existence,
the creature’s sheer size and strength have
destroyed any fighter jets or drones they
have sent after it.
It seems impervious to damage from conventional
weapons, with anything fired at it being almost
perfectly reflected and directed back towards
the shooter.
All the Foundation can really do is hope that
nobody else spots it and keep a close eye
on SCP-4812-K through regular surveillance.
Above all, though, one procedure remains consistent
and of the utmost importance with every aspect
of SCP-4812: Never, under any circumstances,
can any of them be allowed to interact with
the other two.
So, what could possibly connect these three
creatures?
An amorphous entity that kills anyone who
looks at it, a giant humanoid made of platinum
that alters temperature without absorbing
heat, and a winged insect that is almost perfect
at reflecting anything around it.
They all seem to be pretty disconnected.
Yet, their common thread must be pretty significant
for all three to share the title of SCP-4812.
Indeed if they had no relation to each other,
they could each have their own unique number.
And what is the mysterious fourth, redacted
entity that is also referred to as SCP-4812?
The answers to this multitude of questions
aren’t exactly straightforward.
Still, there does exist a series of anomalous
documents and items that the Foundation has
recovered that feature some of the necessary
information.
Recovered from Markus de Wees, a Dutch collector
of anomalous artifacts, these items are referred
to as The Connington Set, named after Winston
J. Connington, an English archaeologist and
occultist whose research led the Foundation
to the discovery of a number of SCPs.
Among the various artifacts of The Connington
Set is a journal kept by Connington himself,
featuring depictions of the different SCP-4812
creatures and notes recording his findings.
The Set also features three hefty tomes written
in German over the course of many years that
contain multiple archaic coordinates.
In one, an addition in Italian by another
author seems to shed a little light on SCP-4812.
The translation of this section tells of an
ancient kingdom, respected above all others.
Known either as the ‘House of Apollyon’,
or the ‘Sky Kings of Old Europ’, the first
ruler of this kingdom was allegedly a descendant
of the King of Crimson Skies, or Asem the
First Man.
These Sky Kings ruled over what is now modern-day
Europe for a hundred generations, conquering
all who opposed them.
Among their adversaries were “those faithful
to the iron god”, presumably the Mekhanites,
the ancient machine-worshipping religion that
preceded The Church of the Broken God.
Eventually, however, complacency reared its
ugly head, and Sky King Sarrus VIII von Apollyon
looked beyond the realms of men, hoping to
find new land to conquer.
Sarrus VIII assembled his forces, the largest
army ever seen, and set his sights on the
lands of the Fair Folk, more commonly known
as fairies nowadays.
These Fair Folk were already engaged in conflict
with their southern neighbors, the Children
of the Moon, and were drastically underprepared
for Sarrus’ approaching forces.
Within two weeks, the fairies were scattered,
driven from their lands.
There was, however, a sole survivor, a fae
princess, who was captured and faced the grim
fate of being taken as a trophy.
But the princess had other plans.
While being taken back to the Sky King’s
domain, she cast a curse upon the House of
Apollyon, and Sarrus VIII in particular.
A horrific storm swept the returning ships
as the fae princess prayed to an ancient,
nameless god for vengeance against her peoples’
conquerors.
According to legend, the chains that had her
shackled to Sarrus’ ship caught fire, and
the blaze spread until it had burned the Sky
King’s ship to ash.
It has even been said that the same chains
then wrapped around Sarrus himself, dragging
him down into the ocean’s depths.
Then, to defend against any further dark magic
from the remaining Fair Folk, Sarrus IX appointed
four knights to defend his kingdom.
By now, you might still be wondering what
any of this has to do with SCP-4812.
But don’t worry, we’re getting there,
we promise.
So, as the story continues, the remaining
ships were still able to bring the fae princess
back, and she was brought before Sarrus’
heir, Sarrus IX von Apollyon, who imprisoned
her for what she had done.
The princess was sent to a sealed dungeon
deep beneath the oceans.
This prison is heavily implied to be the first
of the SCP-4812 entities, better known to
us as SCP-4812-S. However, the explanations
of the heatsink platinum humanoid and the
reflective flying insect are a little harder
to decipher from Winston J Connington’s
journal.
While most of Connington’s notes are written
in a cipher,
a few sections have been translated.
According to him, from her prison deep below
the Earth, the voice of the fairy princess
was able to communicate with the souls of
the four knights protecting Sarrus IX’s
kingdom.
As a result, the Sky King was forced to banish
them, and this brought forth what Connington
referred to as ‘the great profanities’.
Without the knights’ defense, some force
known as the Vinuvinex, the first profanity,
was able to cast its ‘cold hand’ over
Sarrus’ only daughter, killing her.
A creature whose very presence can drain the
heat from a person?
Sounds an awful lot like SCP-4812-E, huh?
In retaliation for his daughter’s death,
Sarrus drew up an ancient spear called the
Godless Lance and struck the being down, casting
it into the Earth’s molten core and subduing
SCP-4812-E with the intense heat below.
Another section describes ‘The King of Many
Faces’, Lamenellant, the creature we know
as SCP-4812-K. Connington’s findings describe
this entity’s slaughter of the Daeva, a
neighboring kingdom.
The enormous insect appeared from the ‘the
space beyond spaces’ and would deflect perfectly
any attack made against it, before taking
the faces of the Daeva and returning to the
skies.
But there was one final profanity, known only
as the Profane Dark.
The legend concludes with this profanity,
a dark, black smear, rising from the graves
of the Fair Folk.
It soaked through the earth and burst from
below, claiming the Sky King and dragging
him into an endless void.
As it pulled him away, Sarrus cursed the Profane
Dark, calling it ‘YASH’, the last great
foe of man.
Watching his kingdom fall without the protection
of his four knights, all the Sky King could
utter was one repeated word:
“Wrath…Wrath, wrath, wrath.”
Now go check out “SCP-1461 - House of the
Worm” and “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” for more wild
stories from the universe of the SCP Foundation!